hey 42 here the average lavatory seat is
much cleaner than the average toothbrush
your teeth are home to 10,000 million
bacteria per square centimeter welcome
to RIF
20 percent of people believe that they
have a food allergy but only two percent
actually do the American Secret Service
tried to spike Hitler's carrots with
female hormones to change him into a
woman Bruce Lee was so fast that they
had to slow the film down so you could
see his moves
cows eat only grass but have twenty five
thousand taste buds two and a half times
as many as humans the CIA reads up to
five million tweets a day the average
American absorbs thirty four gigabytes
of information a day although half of it
is obtained from playing video games if
all the asteroids in the solar system
we're lumped together they'd be smaller
than the moon because there is no
weather on the moon the footprints of
the 12 men who walked on it are still
there
Google owns 20 billion dollars a year
from advertising more than the primetime
revenues of CBS NBC ABC and Fox combined
Angel Falls in Venezuela is 17 times
higher than Niagara Venus rotates so
slowly on its axis that it's day is
longer than its year the entire internet
weighs about the same as one large
strawberry barley has twice as many
genes as people more than 50% of koalas
have chlamydia some parts of Antarctica
have had no rain or snow for two million
years
Mel Bourne used to be called bat mania
thanks for the view subscribe for more